meanwhile it's dialing laura ingraham
she's the founder of life set and she's
the host of the new 10 p.m. show certain
on October 30th
the Ingraham angle good morning to you
Laura cuz I'm a good to see you guys
congratulations on the new book and
we've been seeing all the promos for
your new show we're excited about it I
know I actually haven't seen it yet but
I've been hearing about it so I thought
I better I better watch it and say it I
have to say no you look great
well we are starting this hour with a
Fox News Alert because both Bergdahl is
expected to plead guilty today Laura and
it's interesting about a year ago some
documentary film makers made the film
that we're looking at right here they've
sat on the video for over a year and now
ABC is releasing the video on the day of
the plea deal why exactly is he going to
plead guilty listen to this yes we'll go
back to kangaroo courts and lynch mobs
that got what they wanted the people who
are to a point of saying yeah just shoot
him
you can never convince those people to
change their minds and even though it
does hurt Laura from the people who in
our control room who've seen the video
apparently he says he can't get a fair
trial and he blames among other people
the president United States Donald Trump
well isn't that a shock coming from a
deserter who put his fellow soldiers in
jeopardy and focused on his own
convenience in his own feelings not his
duty to honor and defend the United
States his duty to the US military to
our Constitution a Bo Bergdahl is you
know is playing the blame game we have a
lot of people these days pointing
fingers at others instead of looking at
themselves in the mirror you heard
Hillary yesterday talk about how it's
the Russian deal that caused her to lose
the election and now we have Bowe
Bergdahl I should remind everybody that
the judge and the Bergdahl case told
potential jurors that you know he didn't
strike them if they voted for Trump they
couldn't strike them off the jury
however he did say you know we're gonna
we're gonna ask you about social media
posting about Donald Trump and so forth
so Bergdahl is a deserter is a traitor
of his country and he's blaming the
president okay fine okay
I think we know I think we know what
time it is here and it's ridiculous it's
Monday absolutely yeah at noon today the
president will be meeting sitting down
with the Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
plenty to discuss for them this as last
week of course the president signs
executive actions on Obama care as well
as be certifying the Iran deal Democrats
don't like that they're suddenly now
threatening to shut down the government
but want to blame Republicans for it
where does this political tap-dance go
from here well Republicans have to be
very careful how they message this
Obamacare moved by the president the
president was correct and using his
article one power is Regulatory
Authority his discretion here the
Obamacare exchanges are collapsing
Congress could not get its act together
the house at least passed something but
Mitch McConnell how many swings and
misses could he have on this issue so
Donald Trump got elected in part on the
wall repealing Obamacare obviously trade
and and a less interventionist foreign
policy but he has the upper hand on this
you have two messages correctly the
American people the Democrats are really
good at resistance they've been doing it
since Trump was inaugurated but I if I'm
if I'm Trump and I have McConnell in a
room I say bring me more legislation
that I can sign that we can go around
the country Barnstorm about to the
American people on economic renewal on
this tax reform and all the other
priorities that we have but I need you
to support what I've done on this on the
regulatory front and and mikata
McConnell is the one who's in about what
18 percent approval rating so I think
Trump has about three times the approval
rating approximately as Mitch McConnell
maybe two and a half times but it's it's
ridiculous all right what do you think
about Colin Kaepernick filing grievances
now against the NFL their owners he says
the league is colluding against him
because he's been unsigned now for six
weeks so now we have Hillary blaming the
Russians we have Bergdahl blaming Trump
and we have Kaepernick blant blaming the
owners colluding is there a pattern here
no one no one wants to take
responsibility for their own actions if
Colin Kapernick wanted to kick off this
big protest as he did last year then
okay he did it and now we now we see the
results for the NFL a lot of other
people followed in his footsteps and
they decided to kneel it protests take
their you know protest to the field and
it didn't work out well for them
right if he wants to protest god bless
him go ahead and protest on his own time
he hasn't been selected and everyone I
know who was a bitter bigger expert on
football than I am he's not one of the
top players in the team number one on
the league number one and he's a
disruption to the league it's been a
disaster for the NFL this is this
protest mentality play the game play it
as best you can and Marit Marit should
be the ultimate out there the ultimate
rout King linchpin here not not anything
else but it's okay they're all blaming
other people you're responsible for your
own actions right and this is a
grievance it's not a lawsuit per se but
Laura you're a lawyer now
can't companies hire anybody they want
to for whatever reason they want to
there's no I mean again if we had a
legal system that was was serious about
dismissing frivolous lawsuits this one
would clearly be dismissed and I would I
would slap sanctions on his attorney if
I were that fire with engineer Jha's
yeah I would slap sanctions on him this
is a frivolous lawsuit it has no merit
no basis in fact what Geragos wants to
do is get publicity for Geragos and also
get documents and discovery they think
they could if they get some emails being
sent between owners about him then they
can prove some type of I guess civil a
case that he could have and I think it's
it's very weak but again we people file
lawsuits all the time in the United
States that bankrupt other people not
not the NFL and they should be dismissed
it's it's another example of a stupid
lawsuit that frankly should receive
sanctions on the other end well Laura
this just in
Colin Kaepernick has a supporter Hillary
Clinton at the London Literature
Literature Festival decided to chime in
on whether we should stand or kneel for
the National
take a listen to what she said so you
have to resist what are very clear what
we call dog whistles to that base that's
what the black athletes kneeling was
about that was not against our anthem or
our flag that was actually kneeling as a
reverent position it was to demonstrate
in a peaceful way against racism and
injustice in our criminal system I think
it would be a grave error for Democrats
to receive from those fights and so
therefore we have to stand up fight back
resist isn't this where politics are
today one says stand the other says
kneel stand up fight back resist Hillary
Clinton proving once again why she was
not fit for the presidency she is always
if there's a choice she'll always go on
the wrong side of an issue it in maybe
if this had nothing to do with Trump she
would say something different but that
clip demonstrates once again why it's
not the Russians it's not Jim Comey it's
not Donald Trump being a celebrity that
defeated her last November Hillary
defeated herself she cannot she cannot
deviate from identity politics she has
no solutions for economic prosperity for
this country her foreign policy ideas
were way off the mark and she wanted
open borders she wanted to continue the
trans-pacific partnership all the stuff
that Hillary Clinton was for the voters
rejected and and she again she keeps
proving it every day she's out there
she makes me more glad that we elected
Donald's on Donald J Trump I can tell
you that right now
Laura speaking of losing Jimmy Kimmel
was interviewed and he said he doesn't
care about losing the Republican base
listen to this it's a bit of a risk that
you're taking talking about that stuff
you might lose the audience like three
years ago I was equally liked by
Republicans and Democrats and Republican
numbers went down like 30 percent or
whatever and you know as a talk show
host that's not ideal but I did I would
do it again in a heartbeat so you don't
mind if Republicans turn off your show I
don't say I don't mind I mean I love for
everyone I want
everyone with the television to watch
the show but if they're so turned off by
my opinion on health care and gun
violence then I don't know I probably
wouldn't want to have a conversation
with them anyway good riddance well not
good riddance but riddance does not
regret getting as a tentacle yeah it was
a real probing interview look look he by
all accounts people I know who know him
say he's a great guy and he's I mean I
know a lot of people work really close
friends of his hey they really like him
I think Jimmy you're making a huge
mistake
politics and comedy yeah they do
intersect every now and then but when
people tune in in general at the end of
the end of the day and the late-night
shows they want to laugh they don't want
to feel like they're under attack they
don't want to feel like the guy they
voted for you think it's just a horrible
awful rotten person it doesn't work ask
Oprah how it worked for her after 2008
when she made such a big stand for Obama
she kind of retreated I think smartly
from from injecting politics in her show
so he says he doesn't care and and he
said he probably doesn't have anything
to say to them anyway the Trump voters i
Kimmel I'd want to appeal to all people
in the appeal and I'm happy this is not
just you know theory to you because you
wrote a book about it called shut up and
saying that yeah it was a great book now
you got a new book out it's called
billionaire at the barricades
it is about Donald Trump and you've got
Steve banning and you guys are hitting
the road aren't you yeah we're gonna be
in Scott Scott Scottsdale Arizona
tomorrow at the Hilton make sure to go
to Laura Ingraham comm for details we're
gonna be with Kelly Ward and we're gonna
have a lot of fun it starts at 5:30 that
book signing opens up about 6:30 7:00 so
everybody everybody show up and support
Kelly Ward and we're gonna have fun with
ban and it's always a good time all
right we'll be watching all right okay
all right thank you very much thank you
thank you